fabrice à des vidéos bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous alors vous
vous êtes avocat vous représentez les
collectifs victimes contre les virus
france et le collectif ses 19 ans le
collectif des soignants comment avez
vous réagi à cette annonce
sans surprise c'est le déroulement
normal d'une procédure
à partir du moment où les ministres sont
mises en cause et qu'une information
judiciaire est ouverte à leur encontre
fort naturellement si vous voulez
l'administration devait suivre quoi ton
juge le capitaine du navire on doit
aussi jugé les seconds pour savoir
effectivement quelles sont les
informations qui sont passés entre les
deux en fait tout ça est une équipe
d'ailleurs on parle des kills
gouvernementales et donc il est légitime
et logique que ce soit l'équipe dans son
ensemble qu'il soit finalement mise en
cause quand vous parlez de l'équipe dans
son ensemble
on parle là aussi bien des ministres de
la santé que le directeur de la santé
n'est ce pas absolument le directeur
général de la santé si vous voulez plus
particulièrement en france a une
importance capitale
ici on a ici d'autant plus vrai ici j'ai
envie de dire que jérôme salomon a été
au coeur du pouvoir
il a été au coeur du pouvoir sous
marisol touraine il a été au coeur de la
campagne présidentielle d'emmanuel macro
et il est au coeur du pouvoir sous les
manuels mâcon et souid or philippe est
maintenant sous jean castex
donc il ya quand même effectivement une
question à se poser sur son rôle et
quand agnès buzyn vous rappeler devant
la commission d' enquête à propos des
stocks de masques dit ces choses là ne
remonte pas au ministre alors qui les a
fait sa formation et ben c'est notamment
directeur général de la santé qui les a
et la question qu'on va se poser c'est
pourquoi ne l'at il pas fait remonter
alors cette décision du parquet de paris
arrive tel au bon moment où c'est déjà
trop tard selon vos os trop tard non est
le bon moment c'est celui de la justice
est marrant vous me posez la question
sortie c'est trop tard hier soir m'a
demandé si j'étais trop tôt vous voyez
bien que finalement c'est jamais le bon
moment quoi le moment idéal c'est celui
que fixent la justice
sommes effectivement dans un temps qui
est qui n'est pas le temps de l'homme si
je puis dire la justice fonctionne à son
rythme propre alors n est jamais content
de la justice parfois elle va trop
lentement estime tombent parfois elle va
trop vite
non la vérité c'est que la justice se
fiche royalement des considérations
politiques et sanitaires
la justice a fait son travail en toute
indépendance et c'est particulièrement
heureux je vais vous dire
cinq ans après après avoir lancé une
vaste enquête préliminaire le parquet de
paris a donc nous faire rire ses quatre
information judiciaire qui sont
distinctes qu'est ce que vous en
attendez la vérité on attend la vérité
la vérité parce que le mensonge a été
érigée en règle de gouvernement et qu'on
nous reproche souvent d'avoir saisi la
justice
mais en même temps la justice l alarme
de la vérité c'est à dire que vous avez
vu les perquisitions qui ont eu lieu la
justice
elle a les moyens de faire émerger la
vérité je le dis depuis premier jour et
devant une administration devant un
gouvernement qui a érigé le mensonge en
règle qui a effectivement presque
constitutionnaliser le mensonge dans
cette crise il fallait à contre-pouvoir
pour faire émerger une vérité la vérité
déteste la vérité des masques la vérité
sur ce que dit agnès buzyn qui vit j'ai
averti qu at elle dit quand comment
cette information est elle reçu il est
fini le temps des discours je le dis
depuis maintenant un moment il a terminé
le temps des discours et on me dit
souvent mais finalement les ministres
ont peur et bien c'est bien qu'ils aient
peur puisse-t-il avoir encore plus peur
parce que j'en serai particulièrement
heureux bien sûr qu'il faut qu'ils aient
peur peur de mentir par effectivement
d'avoir des morts inutiles sur la
conscience et si précisément la peur de
mal faire
ne leur suffit pas et bien puisqu'il
avoir la peur d'être condamné
est ce que c'est
ces informations judiciaires vont
permettre justement juge d'instruction
d'aller un peu plus loin dans leurs
investigations notamment les
perquisitions les interceptions
téléphoniques a pensé à lancer cette
gestion de la crise sanitaire
alors je vais vous dire la première
réalité de ces information judiciaire la
première chose fondamentale c'est que
nous avocats des plaignants auront accès
au dossier
nous aurons les procès verbaux
d'audition vous savez que devant la cour
de justice de la république qui est un
ersatz de juridiction nous n'avons pas
effectivement accès au dossier
tout ça est secret là c'est terminé le
temps des privilèges de juridiction
maintenant ce seront des justiciable
ordinaire avec des droits avec des
obligations mais effectivement nous
aurons aussi des droits enfin le droit
de consulter le dossier le droit de
demander des actes le droit de demander
des confrontations et soyez certaine
qu'on va pas s'en priver en fait que les
avocats que nous sommes
n'allons pas nous en priver et que nous
allons demander à ce que mes clients
soient confrontés avec jérôme salomon
avec la présidence santé publique france
que nous demanderons dossier à la cour
de shiso à un public pour savoir ce
qu'on dit les ministres c'est une
bataille judiciaire
j'aurais dire encore accord qui va
commencer aller loin d'être finie mais
pour ce qui nous concerne effectivement
on est prêt merci beaucoup en tout cas
fabrice di vizio d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat spécialiste de santé publique et
vous représentez les collectifs victime
coronavirus france et le collectif ces